questions about whether or not bill
belichick made the right call let's
begin with 12 seconds left in the first
half kicking a field goal from third and
one on the buffalo 15. it was seven to
three at the time
with 12 seconds left you could take a
shot at the end zone and try to take the
lead instead bill belichick decides to
play it safe serene in a game where i
think you go into it not playing it safe
absolutely and he called a low
percentage play and i went on pro
football reference and found that it is
a low percentage place there are 12
plays at the end of a half with 20 or
fewer seconds and only one resulted in a
touchdown but nonetheless i still think
you take that shot to the end zone but
you know immediately what i thought
because i was watching that game live
immediately what i was thought was he
remembers the kansas city game when his
quarterback brian hoyer took the sack
and they got no points out of that drive
and i would almost guarantee you even
though cam newton was at quarterback he
thought i don't trust my quarterback
enough in this situation to take a shot
at the end zone i'm going to take the
points and keep us in this game going
into the second half and he took the
points and he did keep him in the game
going in the second half and they had a
chance to win it at the end without the
cam fumble but it was an interesting
scenario there when when they did have
time to take a shot at the end zone
and that kind of meshes with something
jay glazer reported yesterday on the fox
pregame show that the patriots are very
concerned about the mistakes cam newton
has been making and he denied last week
when he was asked on weei whether or not
he's suffering from brain fog as a
result of cove but you just have to
wonder are they concerned you thr and
the hoyer point is an excellent one
were they concerned he wasn't going to
make a good decision with the football
in that spot and blow the opportunity to
get three points and then
when they didn't
do the aggressive thing at the end of
the half they do the aggressive thing
once they tie the game up at 14 showing
no faith shireen in his defense bill
belichick calls for the ultimate low
percentage play in today's nfl the
onside kick
well it was crazy mike because they had
had a three and out his defense had had
a three and out on the previous
possession on the bill's previous
possession first time all day they had
done that so you think
your defense is playing well you've got
all the momentum i did totally question
that onside kick call you know if it
works it's great he's a he's a genius if
it doesn't work we're sitting here
second guessing it and we are
but he's already a genius he doesn't
even you don't need to prove it to us
bill we agree you're a genius and the
thing is who recovers onside kicks i
mean yes it happens but not nearly like
it used to so uh that that was stunning
to me and and apparently contributed to
the loss of the game because nine plays
later the bill scored they went up 21-14
and they would hold on to win the game
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports